because everyone I'm on and welcome to
my channel as voted for by the people on
my patreon today we are talking about
what the hell Australia is doing in
relation to the debate surrounding gay
marriage Australia is seen as a
progressive country but does have a very
conservative government and gay marriage
is not currently legal so there is an
upcoming poll on gay marriage going to
pull up an excellent article by a friend
of mine actually Jackson Ryan who wrote
kind of all about what this is because
it is a little confusing from the
outside so it is an Australian marriage
law survey being conducted by the
Australian Bureau of Statistics this is
not a referendum or a change to the
Constitution this is literally a very
expensive survey this means that even if
you vote for gay marriage in the
upcoming ballot
the government doesn't actually have to
do anything about it it is voluntary and
occurs by a post rather than at a
polling booth which in my opinion is the
government trying to make it as
difficult for people to participate in
as possible obviously using a postal
service is in favor of the older people
in Australia who are more accustomed to
using the post as a means of
communication so Jackson goes on to
write about why Australia's voting on
same-sex marriage right now or polling
on it the short is that same-sex
marriage was a huge issue in the 2016
election so this post by Jackson online
saga has a whole bunch of other
information about how you can vote for
Australians but I want to get into the
meat of the conversation for anyone
who's watching that is not Australian
but I did want to answer this one
important question does my voice still
count if I draw a dick on the response
form the answer is yes you can draw a
dick or whale or unicorn or anything you
want a new ballot paper as long as there
is a clearly legible mark in a yes or no
box the form only becomes invalid if
there is no clearly legible mark in
either box so that's what it is a 122
million dollar postal vote that is
expensive enough to make people who are
against gay marriage very very very
angry about the issue and also slightly
difficult enough to prevent anyone who's
middling or for gay marriage but no
aggressively for it to not vote this is
something in favor of Australia's very
conservative government and it's gross
so when I found out that we were going
on this as a nation I was at first
excited because this is about time that
I as a young person have ever been able
to give my opinion on something like
this and then I found out that members
of the lgbtq+ community angry about it
and I was very curious as to why but I
will let one of them speak for me this
is from Liam sFlow on Twitter who said
civil rights are not something that
should be voted on by the public their
civil rights I've been with my partner
for over ten years frankly I'm tired of
having my legal and civil rights debated
by people who tell me my sexuality is a
choice and that I'm going to health is
something I can't control for the next
three weeks all I'm going to see every
day is people telling me how disgusting
I am how unnatural my relationship with
my partner is how my identity is bad
business - presiding judgment of them
I'm angry with the government said
denying my civil rights and then
deciding to treat them as political
football I'm angry with my government
they're not dealing with this issue
quickly and efficiently so we can move
to other important issues at base our
country trans rights
I'm lessness basic communications
infrastructure so everyone's pissed off
really
conservatives pissed off because it's
expensive and Li Cleese gay is a costing
us one hundred and twenty-two million
dollars then the lgbtq+ community is
angry because they look at it as like
this is literally written as a civil
right marriage is a right why are we
still voting on this in 2017 one of
these sides is not hurting the other one
of these sides just wants to be able to
get married I was talking to a lesbian
about her grandmother she said something
along the lines of grandmothers getting
old and she's been in and out of
hospital for the past two years and all
she wants is to see me get married and
there are hateful bigoted people across
our country who are preventing her from
being able to do that that just crushed
me because marriage equality is just
something that affects two people it
also affects their entire families there
are parents who have dreamed of seeing
that kids get married one day who can't
because of the person that they fell in
love with it's a conservative person
versus an lgbtq+ person and
every single person that they interact
with and the goddamn suicide rates that
rise every time issues like this come up
because it encourages more angry people
to jump on everyone
it's just embarrassing Australia it is
embarrassing
and this jerk right here is an example
of someone who does not want this past
so liberal senator Eric abets says that
legalizing same-sex marriage industry
like lead to people marrying the Sydney
Harbour Bridge in an interview with
BuzzFeed and you the best said that if
the Parliament legalized the same sex
marriage falling and yes result in the
upcoming postal survey it could lead to
humans legally marrying inanimate
objects you said the issue is if we are
judging this solely on a person's view
of what love is to them and people ask
me how can you judge somebody else's
love then I think you've got to accept
that love is love and that's the slogan
but there's something very gross about
acquiring people to objects and also you
know how many people have married
bridges or inanimate objects in New
Zealand after a marriage equality bill
was passed
none it's not how that works so then of
course with this comes the discussion of
people asking why marriage matters
anyway
for legal reasons rather than
sentimental reasons so the biggest one
is that married partners have immediate
access to all relationship entitlements
protections and responsibilities
de-facto couples which are couples
who've lived together person amount of
time and have some of the same benefits
as married couples but not entirely both
have to live together for a certain time
before they're deemed to have legal
rights and in emergency situations may
have to prove to a judge that they are
legally in a de facto relationship you
get a homophobic judge she can say I
think that it's a friendship that you
have and not a romantic relationship
sorry this is specifically in reference
to a situation where someone needs to
make an important medical call and if
you are not married you may not legally
have the right to be able to make a call
on behalf of your partner you may not
get access to any of their accounts or
money or things that you would normally
have liked to there are a bunch of
again people who have said is much
better than me I'll leave a link below
to Australian marriage equality org but
one thing that I think is very important
to mention is that the failure of the
law to allow same-sex couples to marry
sends out the message that it is okay to
discriminate on the grounds of sexual
orientation and gender and at the end of
the day all it will do is remove
discrimination for marriage in the same
way discrimination was removed when
interracial couples were allowed to
marry in the 1960s all right you guys
that is it for me today my next video
will actually be going up on my birthday
August 24th I'll be in Germany and I'll
see y'all next time
bye